okay welcome back everyone
in this segment we're going to talk
about how mining works so let's see what
the miners actually do
so this one picture is going to explain
exactly what miners do in these
blockchains so i'll use again one of our
examples i'll use the bitcoin blockchain
to illustrate it but it's actually quite
similar in many blockchains that
actually happen to use proof of work
okay proof of work is one consensus
mechanism okay so what do we do so we
have a collection of miners uh
potentially all over the world
these miners operate equipment that
allows them to write onto the blockchain
and the way this works is as follows
basically we have our set of users
these users basically issue transactions
into the uh into the network the bitcoin
network in this case yeah so here we
have four transactions being issued into
the bitcoin network
and then one miner
succeeds in creating a block out of
these transactions and what he does is
he writes these blocks onto the onto the
bitcoin blockchain yeah so you can see
here is transaction number one
transaction number two up to transaction
number four
now i should say in addition what the
miner does is he writes what's called
transaction zero this is often called
the coinbase transaction and the
coinbase transaction pays the miner for
the work that he did in creating this
block yeah so currently in the bitcoin
network the miner gets 12 and a half
bitcoins for every block that they mine
okay so that's how uh miners uh
operate yeah they collect transactions
from users they make a block out of it
post it to the blockchain and then they
get paid for the for the work they did
in creating this block
so then in this time maybe another miner
creates the block and again this miner
now is the one that receives the coin
base the twelve and a half bitcoin
uh but it's the different miner that
creates uh this particular block and so
on and so forth so forth basically
blocked kind of get created so yes so
the users basically publish transactions
the miners assemble these transactions
into blocks and then they post these
blocks onto the blockchain so what i
want to talk about is specifically how
do the miners actually assemble the
blocks and who decides which miner is
the one that's going to post the block
to the blockchain
okay so yeah so how do we choose the
minor that creates a new block
so
at a high level our goal is basically to
choose the minor at random from the set
of all minors why do we want to choose
the minor at random well what this
guarantees is that basically anyone in
the world can mine so if i want to start
creating bitcoin blocks basically i can
just hook up to the bitcoin network
start mining and you know i can be
hopeful that maybe i can create some
blocks yeah and of course if i create a
block i get paid the fees plus the
coinbase
mining reward
now the fact that anyone can mine
is a way to ensure liveness because if
for example a collection of miners
decide that they don't want to accept
transactions from me
well that's okay i can go to another
miner and ask that other miner to mine
my transaction um and eventually you
know he'll succeed and get my my
transaction onto the blockchain i can
even try to mine the transaction myself
if i wanted to so in theory this is a
way to sort of guarantee that no one can
prevent me from posting transactions
also as although as we'll see in
practice things work a little
differently okay so the problem with
choosing a minor at random is what we
call a sybil attack so a sybil attack is
where a single entity controls a very
large majority of the miners yeah more
than 51
of the miners
if they control a large number of miners
what that means is first of all they're
very likely to get chosen every time so
again that goes against the idea of
liveness if they get chosen every time
that entity gets chosen every time it
can block people from posting
transactions
yeah so you can post block people from
posting transactions it might even
decide to only post empty blocks
blocks that only contain the coinbase
and essentially kind of block the system
from making any progress because no
longer legitimate transactions are not
getting through so simple attacks are
kind of a real problem and it's
something that we have to defend defend
against when we define design these
blockchains
okay yeah and as it turns out by the way
if you have a majority of miners it
turns out in some designs you can even
revert some transactions which is kind
of countered to the persistence property
that blockchains are trying to provide